okay
let's talk about bank of walmart you
guys okay with that let's talk about
banco walmart so
why walmart could become a serious
player in banking as walmart looks to
launch a fintech startup the retailer is
turning to wall street veterans to help
into moving
into the banking world they picked up
two senior bankers from goldman sachs
omer ismail the head of goldman sachs
consumer bank and david stark
one of his top lieutenants to help lead
the retailer's
new fintech startup i don't think in
here it talks about marcus but we'll get
into that here in a minute
walmart announced earlier this year that
it was partnering with rivet capital
the firm backing fintech startups such
as robinhood to offer financial products
for customers and employees customers
have made it very clear they want to
move more from us in the financial
services
arena president and ceo of walmart us
john furner said in a statement
walmart's current financial service
offering include the walmart capital one
credit card
the prepaid walmart money card and the
ability for people to cash
checks in stores they're saying if
walmart goes into the banking business
they
immediately become one of the biggest
if they go into that world thoughts i
think it's a very smart strategy on
their behalf
they are they've managed to become
such an important global player as it
relates not just retail
pharmacy you name it walmart
just has figured it out and i think it's
very wise for them because
if people are going there anyway most of
america shops at walmart right i mean
that's how it is i think it's a really
important place for them and i know the
the company ribbit capital the venture
capital firm uh they invest a lot in
cryptocurrency and like really
alternative fintech
startups and for them to partner up with
with walmart i think it's
it's baller as well i like that
here's the question when's the last time
you the luxury real estate
guru shopped at walmart um i don't know
six years ago you're not gonna find
sonata
okay i'll go to target oh
yeah okay so you will not go to walmart
[Laughter]
that is the fancy term well let me tell
you my little experience
where was i this past sunday now that
i'm back here in south florida where was
i is anyone who saw my instagram
aisle seven no i was not i was on a boat
i was on a yacht shout out to my uh my
best friend keith mann and his wife
evelyn manning it was her birthday we
had a great time that was my sunday in
miami kai where did i go every sunday
when i was in addison texas
you went to walmart off of beltline wild
march sundays
there was nothing else to do i mean i
was just i had my walmart sundays
so and part of it was there's a
two-prong approach here
if you live in miami beach or down to
miami there's not a walmart for miles
nowhere so when i moved into thank you
for your
by the way this guy got me my apartment
and i said go check out the vpnm over
there
and and you make that recommendation
right next to the article thank you i
don't know if you guys were there to
witness this the day we announced we're
moving to florida you were devastated
you were dead no not back to miami let
me see walmart it felt like
a very tough conversation tough tough
but i'd go to this walmart and i was
shocked by how cheap i'm yeah
inexpensive things were shocked i mean
you're talking about in florida
you know you shop at publix it's you
know pretty standard you go to whole
foods or trader joe's
things are a little pricier there like i
felt like they were giving things away
at walmart
okay and and slowly but surely i started
getting indoctrinated to this walmart
lifestyle
and damn uh you know things are
very cheap so then i started seeing the
types of people that are shopping
at walmart so it's very interesting to
back to this story
um walmart's current financial service
offerings include the walmart capital
one credit card
a prepaid walmart money card and the
ability for people to
cash checks in stores they are not these
are not to have people
buying 25 million houses these are types
of people that maybe make
25 000 a year so
you know you're playing like trump plays
to his base they're going after
low-income or even middle-income
americans
and what we've realized certainly since
the pandemic
is the k-shaped economy the rich are
getting richer they're gobbling up 20
million
houses like it's uh gumballs but the
rest of america
you know the rest of america has
suffered tremendously has suffered
tremendously in the bottom
on the bottom half of the the k-shaped
economy so
where are they getting their financial
services from a lot of them are already
going
to walmart they're cashing their checks
they're doing you know
their prepaid cards so if walmart wants
to play to their base
you know the 25 of americans who have no
financial education they have no savings
they have
zero credit they've got just financially
a mess
you know and a part of my brand is
helping people like this get smarter
um i think that they can be a player in
the
low-income middle-income american well
what does that mean does player mean top
five
top three can they compete at the top
what does player mean to you yeah
i mean look you know ftm follow the
money
so they're gonna need the law of large
numbers
to to compete they're going to need
millions and millions and millions of
low-income americans
to say all right i'm done with bank of
america i'm done with chase
you know wells fargo screwed me over one
too many times
i'm a walmart guy now i'm a walmart gal
and
you know they're gonna would you
consider yourself a walmart like no but
wait a minute actually a serious
question but your whole spiel about you
go to walmart a lot kind of hurt your
game a little bit
you never bring that up i'm very
transparent you don't go on a date and
you say hey mary good to meet you first
time by the way i was at walmart the
other day
at least he'll know that they like him i
will take them to walmart and see how
they
their selective process i will take them
on a date to walmart high end
take any serial you anything you want
baby i got you don't know we're going to
walmart
is beautiful this time of year that's
true sure so paul's going to say
something about walmart but before you
do it
you're going to make a point question i
was going to ask you is this walmart
opens up
the banking set would you open up an
account with them zero percent chance
zero percent less than zero yeah i'm not
i'm not banking at walmart
like no like so fine not a good level by
the way
keep this piece and record it shop
shopping
watching shopping for seriously on
avocados
i got my walmart black card y'all go
ahead go ahead paul
i think a big part of where they can
succeed in this arena
is the bank culture and the bank
industry themselves they have a culture
right it's that
eight to five and they're not open past
five o'clock if walmart
offers because one of their big benefits
because even when i was driving
like from here to texas yeah like i
needed a couple things and i'm like
where's a walmart at and i know i can
count on them
that's a good point so if they can do
that same thing in the banking industry
and be like hey i need to go
to the bank at nine o'clock at night
i'll i'll be let me ask you
let me ask you paul e yeah would you ch
who's your bank right now
uh it's a southern goal don't say what's
that people may go try to get away you
want to start
banking at walmart you if they offer
what i just said
if there are more convenient because
like i don't go to the bank anymore
but i if i need an app i need an app you
would bank at walmart i would bank at
walmart
boom you don't go to the bank anymore no
what do you mean because everything you
do is online
everything's online okay my bank's in
california okay fair enough so
so so here's the here's the follow-up
question for you a couple things to be
thinking about
do you know 97 of america lives within
10 miles of a walmart
let me say this one more time 97
of america lives within 10 miles of a
walmart goes back to your point
okay do you know how many people
per year walk through walmart walk not
not not if you walked in 19 times you
don't count us 19 times
how many i'm just one time individual
yeah 200 million i was going to say
somewhere around
a couple hundred million 100 million but
not sonata she hasn't been there in
seven years
well maybe they're going to get her
business now but watch out would you
would you
consider banking at walmart if she hears
about that's not happening well
here hear me out for a second hear me
out for a second so first of all
what is robin hood robin hood is for
what low income and middle america
that's what they're targeting
great who's goldman sachs when you think
about goldman sachs what do you think
about
high-end high i'm going to cry you need
10 million to get in if you don't have
10 million by the way they only have 400
advisors morgan merrill have 13 000 they
only have 400
and they have 400 to say we don't need
13 we only have 400 because we get the
cream of the crop
cornell university penn you know wharton
those are the kind of guys that we get
that come to us okay great
but the two guys they recruited i don't
know if you've looked into it these two
guys are
the two guys that were recruited omar
ismail was the head of
golden consumer bank that's what you
just read that they said go
and hear david stark partner at goldman
david is the right hand guy to omar
at goldman sachs omar led the way
because
goldman saw what was happening with
robin hood and others and acorn
so they started a branch called marcus
invest yeah
mark is to get in you only need a
thousand dollars to go into having an
account so goldman sachs who has been
the cream of the crop you need 10
million to come in if you don't have 10
million we're not even doing anything
with you
unless if you're part of the family they
saw the trend and they said let's go
open up marcus
to allow people to come in you answer
the questionnaire minimum investment you
need to make is what a thousand dollars
now you got an account phenomenal idea
right it's okay
great name by the way by the way last
year
just the marcus business model generated
1.2 billion dollars in revenues
97 billion dollars deposited into
markets
let me say this one more time just last
year 1.2 billion dollars in revenues 97
billion
is invested into marcus last year around
2020 during the pandemic
and this is who walmart these are the
two guys they recruited
smart so they recruited away the guys
who led
marcus to go to walmart so now they're
gonna go to walmart bring that
experience from goldman sachs they
recruited the main guys
you want to recruit they're going to
more to walmart now
97 of america lives within 10 miles 200
million people that are visiting walmart
you got all this business now you got a
banking all the locations traffic's
already coming in
you know then the question becomes who's
an ally who's an enemy meaning
who wants to see this become a reality
who doesn't want to see this become a
reality
does bfa want to see this become a
reality does chase want to see this
become a reality
do they want to see this become a
reality who does want to see them become
a reality does a robin hood does a
goldman do the who
who is it so i think that's going to be
the battle but walmart
you know the number one enemy of walmart
is who who's the number one
amazon amazon's the number one enemy is
this
also gonna be the first mover where
amazon next
is gonna wanna come up with bank is this
when
all these other guys are gonna shoot you
know we get all this money that's coming
in maybe we got to play ball
and can amazon compete at the level
walmart can this is an
area where amazon cannot compete with
walmart
this is one area right is it because
they have
actual stores 97
10 miles got it so i can say to you 97
of americans are within 10 miles of my
bank called the bank of walmart
that's that's very very interesting the
angle they took
if you think about it because it's what
amazon cannot directly compete with them
in
a couple of thoughts um we were joking
about the walmart thing
and we talked about goldman sachs and
marcus if
from an optic standpoint and a branding
standpoint and pr standpoint
you can't be bank of walmart you got to
come up with
you know a fancier name or a marcus type
of a thing
for it to be a little more palatable if
you're going to convert people like if
you're already banking at walmart and
you're cashing your checks there you're
going to freaking walmart whatever
but if they come up with a you know an
attractive name and it's
whatever fair enough you know people
will will be a little more
opt to go there that's number one number
two
uh you brought up amazon you know we
learned anything from jack ma's
ant group what was the what's their
whole company that they're doing over
there uh
the ant group and alibaba the whole
fintech like you're banking you're
shopping you got your id
you got your driver's license you got
your credit card you've got
every financial service tool boom on
your phone
okay so there's a model out there for
amazon
to potentially emulate and obviously
walmart is kind of playing in that
and that thing but to paul's point does
it really matter that you live
near your bank because banking is online
anyways how often do you go into your
bank anyway
so i get it that it's cool to live
near a bank maybe you know where you're
shopping don't forget how often do you
need to do that you are
rich to middle america adam don't forget
who you are
you you may not be selling 25 million
dollar homes but
you're you still made your money it's
not like you're making fifty thousand
dollars
you don't know what it is to be 50k
right now you don't know
the level of trust like you know how i
don't know if you guys got family where
they say
oh i don't trust a you know online i
like to go to a physical but there's
still people like that that want to go
to a place and it's typically folks that
make 25
35 45 55 000
that's their market so they're targeting
their own they're not targeting you
they're not targeting you they're not
targeting
but they are targeting that so yes i
think there's one interesting thing as
well that you're not necessar that you
guys haven't brought up at least uh
walmart has 4 700 locations in
america i mean you overnight they can
have 4
700 locations with a bank imagine you
know how apple
also did their card where you get
certain cash back you get certain
discounts and stuff like that imagine if
walmart does that where you get two
percent cash back on
on groceries imagine the 200 million
people that go
shopping there i i automatically agree
10
20 30 40 50 overnight can switch over
and just have an extra it's it's the
it's the look look at the way they did
good for them man
good you know i'd love to see walmart
and amazon
do you want to say that i just want to
see that i want to see if i want to see
a heavyweight match up because
think about think about when amazon
bought
whole foods you're like what is that
tell you thinking
yeah and and people are wow you know
it's just not not really a good move
it's just you know
it's like yeah okay okay buddy so then
amazon if you're an amazon are you an
amazon prime member
yes can you please put in your number
matter of fact just go to your app
and show the thing qr code boom oh you
just got a nine dollar discount
hmm i paid 99 bucks for prime and wow
okay so now you're going back to whole
foods they charge 20
more than a regular place but you feel
healthier when you buy it whole foods so
funny same thing
they feel healthy paycheck guy's a
genius the guy who set it up by the way
so i don't know i i kind of think this
could be very interesting
and i don't think amazon could compete
directly with these guys
not in this area may i make one more
point which is
in the past the american dream was
owning a home right
now the american dream is being an
investor so even if you look
at what happened a few weeks ago with
gamestop a lot of these
investors and and people who are part of
robin hood
they're all they're students they're you
know
people who make whatever they make and
they want to feel like they're part of
that american dream
which so i think there is this huge
transformation and evolution
of what it means to be successful in
this country and if you feel like
you're part of the whatever it looks
like be it
you know invest investment in stock
market and now walmart i think this
is incredible because like you said they
have a captive audience
they have millions they probably have
details of every single american citizen
data
you think about the data so the data is
that's that's where the power is you
have captive audience so how do you just
smartly and strategically incorporate a
whole new
um segment of of business i wonder if
they sat there and they said what can we
do that amazon can't do
i wonder if that was the board meeting
what can we do
like you know the whole blue ocean
strategy concept is you're going to
compete with somebody not directly in an
area that they're weak and i wonder if
they sat there
and the brains in that board was what's
the one thing they cannot do
banking let's go into it so if walmart
now you're buying your loan
from walmart you buy a house you get
your loan 300 000 loan from walmart
times
millions i mean that's that can really
scale that can really scale
and and you know as far as the name goes
i mean walmart's used to have a new name
sam's club
you know they have you know they don't
sam's club is owned by walmart
sam walton sam's the founder sam's club
sam walton sam's club yeah okay
they could come out with a new name it's
not a big deal you were gonna say
something if you look at it the way
apple has their ecosystem of the apps
the app store kind of how everything is
kept within it
imagine how walmart can do that with
with banking as well i mean then you're
just controlling
i am a lot of forward to this
heavyweight oh this could get
so interesting so interesting one thing
i've definitely
realized slash learned about you you
you light up when you think about
competition oh yeah when you think of
walmart versus amazon you like genuinely
like oh yeah baby let's get that
competition kidding me love it
of course i love you you want to compete
the night connor lost to
portugal i'm like what you know because
we wanted to see a khabib fight yeah
of course you want to see a fight like
that but this you realize this is the
ultimate heavyweight yeah yeah yeah this
is trillion dollar companies going up
against these well it's like facebook
and apple kind of
talking smack getting into it that's the
heavyweight stuff i don't think so
i don't think so i don't think so
because facebook and apple
no okay okay let me adam i can't believe
you went over there
so so mr growled up i went there watch
this year
watch this yesterday okay what
percentage
of facebook's revenue comes from
ads don't say it what do you know it
already well we talked about it okay so
what is it it's like 98
98 yeah okay crazy
apple's revenue 98 doesn't come from one
product
so what amazon and walmart are playing
they're trying to go dominate
other facebook is not playing that game
facebook's playing the ad game
facebook's competition is nbc cnn fox
data data it's know what i'm trying to
all the game they're playing is
you're going to come advertise and put
your commercials with me you're going to
come spend your ads with me not with
these other schmucks because people are
on this year
they're no longer watching so facebook's
a complete different animal yeah
and by the way to them to that to their
strength
they're in a position that they're
probably the hardest to directly compete
with
facebook's not easy to directly compete
with who's going to directly compete
google plus try to come out with a
social media site how long did how many
guys actually posted more than five
things on google plus
never even heard of it
google plus came out it was their
facebook they got 50 million subscribers
a month one they said they're going to
blow up they're going to be facebook
i never once posted on anything when
when did that when was here what year
was that's the point yeah i never heard
of it
[Laughter]
i know i know uh google plus like sonata
knows joe jorgensen i just i don't
okay what so so so that guy so here's a
question for everybody that's watching
if you think
if you think bank of walmart will
compete
thumbs up if you think i don't think
they're going to compete with bank of
america and all the other guys thumbs
down i'm curious we got 6 36 to 34.
by the way the last one i asked the
question can trump win without
yeah uh it was three to one which means
three people said he still can
one said he cannot so it's interesting
to see what the staff we know some of
the people in our audience well we'll
see what's going on i agree
so regardless okay so are you bottom
line is are you
rooting for walmart to beat amazon i say
compete
beat i i am rooting for walmart to
make the banking industry uncomfortable
i am rooting for walmart to make amazon
uncomfortable because you know who wins
here
the consumer baby that's why you love
capitalism yeah
yeah that's why you love capitalism
because it works it's not about you it's
about the consumer when
at the end of the day you win at the end
of the day it's interesting how you
light up when you talk about these kind
of things there's something in your
bones that this is in your dna
capitalism competition well you know
taking over here you have a top realtor
who worked for a capitalist left
socialistic communistic nation to come
to u.s you got a guy like me who lived
in iran
what do you want to call that it's not
socialistic dictate
totality fascists what do you want to
call it women don't have any freedom you
can't vote
girls get married at 13 years old i mean
that's iran's laws it's what you're
talking about and
we leave we go to germany we come here
and then you can build the kind of life
that you got here
yeah capitalism works you work for a
capitalist
you work for a capitalist i work for a
capitalist we're all capitalists
everybody every
i my commission that comes from
insurance companies comes from because
somebody started a business that's a
capitalist capitalism
the only way the socialism argument
exists is because of a capitalist
only way if there is no capitalism there
is no other argument no other isms
if it wasn't because of capitalism no
isms comes
first the first ism that comes is what
capitalism no otherism you need money to
be able to spend the money
and the capitalists know how to make the
money so others can come out with their
own
individual isms whatever those isms
may be right so yes i'm a die-hard
capitalist and i will keep saying that
for the rest of my life so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you